[Music]
hello dear friends welcome to our
program i'd like to know
i am daniel miranda associate speaker
here at secrets and seal and also
secrets and sealed latino today for our
program as always i am in the company of
two great men
on my right hand i have pastor c murray
he is also associate speaker
for secrets and seal pastor c murray is
always good to have you here with us
good to be with you and good to study
the word of god with you amen and on my
left
uh we have our dear pastor stephen bohr
he is the president and also speaker for
this ministry pastor bohr is always good
to have you also here it's always a
pleasure to be here i just want to
mention that ca is also
the senior media consultant for secrets
unsealed good yep so um
you know this is a brand new title that
we've given him which is well deserved
amen anyway it's a pleasure to be here
thank you yeah
and you all thank you for
watching our program and sending your
questions as you can tell we have many
many questions
and you might be wondering why your
question hasn't been answered yet well
the reason is because we take them in
order and we have a big stack there you
go
and
you just have to be patient but we'll
get your question we promise before we
begin i'd like to remind you that if you
want to participate in our program
sending your questions you can do it so
to the following email address tv at
samtv.org
again this is tv at some tv
s-u-m dot o-r-g
before we begin i would like to ask
pastor c murray to please lead us in
prayer as we study the word of god be
glad to do so
shall we pray father god again we thank
you for your word which is a lamp unto
our feet
and enlightened to our path we thank you
for the power of your word for the
information
the inspiration
and that if we will put these things
into practice they will direct our lives
here on earth
as we prepare for the higher citizenship
which is in the world to come amen so we
ask you now lord feed us from your word
and help us to do that which we know to
be right may everything that is said and
done come from your word and be based on
your word and we thank you for your
uh promise to hear and answer the prayer
of faith in jesus name amen amen very
good
okay so we have
our first question today that comes from
kempton alert
and the question is about the worship of
the holy spirit i'm going to read the
question it's a short one it says
greetings pastor boar
a seventh-day adventist and my brother
hit me with a question that we should
worship the holy spirit i know we
shouldn't
am i just wrong
can you help me answer that question
thank you
well we have clear bible verses in the
bible that tell us that we are to
worship the father
for example revelation 4 verse 11
yes there are also
texts that say that we should worship
jesus like in hebrews chapter 1.
there is no explicit text in the bible
that says that we're supposed to worship
the holy spirit
however
there is a text which i'm going to ask
ca to refer to
where we are told that the holy spirit
helps us
in our prayer life and then maybe you
can offer a little explanation ca about
what that means all right so you're you
are referring to romans chapter eight
and i just want to get it here
i think your point while i'm while i'm
turning that is very very well taken the
fact that we don't find an example in
the bible either implicitly or
explicitly where worship is offered to
the holy spirit
i think i'm in romans chapter 8
26 and i need to go just one page more
to verse 26 likewise
the spirit also helps in our weaknesses
for we do not know
what we should pray for as we ought i'm
reading from the new king james but the
spirit himself not itself himself makes
intercession for us with groanings which
cannot be
uttered that's right
it's a text full of of of important
statements
the holy spirit is pleased to be the one
who facilitates our worship as opposed
to being the author of our worship
um our prayers uh lack the
let me throw in a 50 cent word gravitas
that they should have and so the holy
spirit dresses your prayers up gives
urgency unction to your prayers and
presents them
before the father so
he is
he is intimately involved in the worship
experience
in the prayer life experience but rather
than being the object he is the
facilitator of worship and that's what
we see here in in romans
8 26
and the interesting thing is
the holy spirit actually enlightens our
mind
to help us
understand what we should ask for
because it says in the text we don't
know what to ask for yes we think we do
many times
but we don't really know what our
innermost need is until the holy spirit
shows us our condition and shows us what
we really need
and so the holy spirit is called the
helper in the bible
because he helps us in our prayer life
to know what to ask when to ask how to
ask
because he searches the deep things of
god amen well said
go ahead well i'm
the text that the pastor just alluded to
in john 16
however when he the spirit of truth is
come he will guide you into all truth so
we know that he is a
the one who leads us into in truth and
convicts us of that that truth for he
will not speak on his own authority but
but whatever he hears he will speak and
he will tell you things to come
he will glorify me again another
job or say of the holy spirit to glorify
christ to lift up christ so he will
glorify me
for he will take of what is mine and
declare it to you so he explains the
things of god right to us so the holy
holy spirit is very involved in our
worship life in our prayer life in our
relationship with the lord but not as
object more as facilitator
yes
in fact in first john chapter 3 verse 24
we understand that in the bible another
way to worship is to obey right we
worship god also by obedience
and see the place of the holy spirit in
that experience it says here in first
john chapter 3 verse 24
now he who keeps his commandments abides
in him
and he in him
and by this we know that he abides in us
by the spirit whom he has given us amen
so
the spirit also helps us
keep the commandments of god and keeping
the commandments of god is an act of
worship yes so we also see here
work of the holy spirit helping us obey
god and worship god yeah in addition
ellen white makes a statement
i don't have the exact reference
in my head right now but she says
the greatest praise we can give to the
lord
is is not necessarily
the
the praise that comes from our mouth
although that is important she says the
greatest praise is is obedience to him
yes so uh that sort of dovetails with
with your statement uh and chimes right
and if the greatest thing you can do is
obey him and of course the it is the
spirit that allows us gives us the
strength to do that so uh the greatest
praise we can render to god is again
facilitated by the holy spirit you know
when i was pastor
of the fresno central seventh avenue
church i had an associate pastor he was
a retired pastor but he was helping
there in the church his name was james
finn
he had several sayings that stuck in my
mind that i remember to this day one of
those was
obedience
is the highest form of worship amen
and that's true
because you can praise the lord with
your mouth and if you're disobedient yes
that worship is not acceptable in sight
so
the basic answer to this question is
nowhere in the bible are we told to
worship the holy spirit even though we
know the holy spirit is god according to
scripture okay you know it is very easy
and and i'll close with this for me um
to add
add laws onto
the laws that are written in the bible
of course the jews had donated 7000 laws
by the time christ came along because it
seems logical it seems like it makes
sense so you add it uh but it is not
necessary nor is it in the plan of god
each of uh
the
aspects of god have have certain roles
certain functions and they function in
complete harmony and it is not the
spirit's place to receive worship but to
to add to it and the bottom line is the
bible tells us how we're supposed to
pray we're supposed to address the
father in the name of
jesus that's right
okay very good
thank you for your question let's go to
our next question today from kedar wade
and this question has to do with the
wearing of hat in the church
uh here
the message says the question is it our
culture for some in the caribbean
jamaica
that hat wearing must be practiced
it if this is right or it or maybe the
question is not well put but is this
right or is it a sin
based on first corinthians 11 verses 1
through 10 which speaks about the veil
if not observed
you are criticized
so the question has to do here with
whether wearing a hat in the church is
sin or is it wrong or right and then the
person asked if first corinthians 11
verses 1 through 10 shed some light on
that on that
you know in
very conservative roman catholic
countries to this day
the older women
wear a veil
when they go into
into the church
it's a it's a cultural custom yes and
it's a sign of reverence it's a way of
demonstrating reverence
now there are other places
where you can show reverence for god for
example you can kneel when you show
reverence for god that's an external
sign of respect to god
in other countries somebody might bow
you know in as a sign of reverence so
the cultural expression
teaches a very important principle
and the principle is
worship to god
and rendering the homage that god
deserves
now the way in which that principle is
expressed might vary from country to
country but the principle doesn't change
you know i've given this example before
um
one time i visited a church member um
and uh he had a pile of books on his
table
and the bible was at the bottom of the
pile
and that kind of bothered me you know
because my parents taught me that the
bible always goes on top
and so it bothered me so much that
as usual i was quite
blunt
i said to him brother
don't you think
that that bible should actually be on
top of all of books and not in the
bottom of the books
he says why
i said well the reason is that because
the bible is above
all knowledge
he looked at me he says
but the bible is also the foundation of
all knowledge
so how could i argue with that happy
comeback
so you know
the the point is that the bible is above
all knowledge because it's the
foundation of all knowledge the way of
expressing the principle varied but the
principle didn't exactly
if you allow me to read a statement from
ellen y where she addresses this issue
and let's try to draw some principles
based on what paso bohr said in regards
to this question this this quote comes
from testimonies volume 5
page 498
paragraph three
ellen y is talking about the behavior in
the house of god and she says in the
minds of many
there are no more sacred thoughts
connected with the house of god
than with the most common place some
will enter the place of worship with
their hats on in soiled dirty clothes
such do not realize that they are to
meet with god and holy angels
there should be a radical change in this
matter all through our churches
ministers themselves need to elevate
their ideas to have finer
susceptibilities in regard to it
it is a feature of the work that has
been sadly neglected
because of the irreverence here this is
the principle because of the irreverence
in attitude dress and deportment and
lack of a worship frame of mind
god has often turned his face away from
those assembled for his worship
so the question is is ellen white
condemning here hats or what is the
principle behind it well what i get here
is the principle behind it is reverence
in the house of god
now as passover was saying if it is
culturally accepted
and if in your culture having a hat
inside of the church is not considered
in modest or disrespectful or irreverent
then i wouldn't see a problem wearing a
hat in the
caribbean culture i've never been to the
caribbean but maybe you have
and you can evaluate that
that custom better there
it was also
very common i don't know if it still is
in african-american congregations for
women to come in hats oh very much so my
mother until the day she died never
never went to church for worship service
he did the afternoon service without a
hat on her head uh and in all the
churches i i pastored
uh very common my i'm caribbean
background my father's from barbados
mother from canada uh through panama you
know
back to the caribbean and uh that was a
very very very common thing a few years
ago a book came out made the new york
times the bestseller called crowns
it was black and white pictures of women
in church hats very very popular about
oh maybe about two inches thick
called crowns very very popular
and it went back through the history of
wearing hats and churches and kind of
thing so that is it's cultural to be
sure but it is a cultural expression of
reverence and uh there are some churches
you couldn't some people you couldn't
get into the church building for worship
without a hat on their head
and sometimes very elaborate hats
but that's that's just the culture and
that brings up the issue
of is an extravagant
hat
that attracts attention to the person
yes
really a sign of reverence to god
that would be an important issue
you know and it would apply to dress as
well
particularly women
you know
i've seen some women in adventist
churches that come
with
very short skirts
and you know
blouses that
that are not blouses that show reverence
for god
so per se
i don't think wearing a hat
is wrong in itself particularly if it's
a cultural thing true
but even that can be carried too far and
attract attention to the person yes and
so
we need to make sure that when we go
into the sanctuary we go dress in a way
in which people are not attracted to us
but people can focus their attention
only on god on god and by the way in
that chapter behavior in the house of
god ellen white also mentions
that if there are individuals in the
church
that don't have a special garment for
sabbath
the church should
make a collection or provide a special
garment for people to go to church on
sabbath in other words a person who goes
to church on sabbath and work clothes
yes
it's not a sign of worship to the lord
right yeah so
and if you go in dirty clothes it's not
a sign of worship to god
we're going to meet before the king of
the universe amen you know i've seen
pastors that are that
you know might not believe this but i've
seen pastors that have preached on
sabbath morning in shorts
and a bermuda shirt oh wow
you know or hawaiian shirt
you know totally unacceptable yeah it's
a total sign of disrespect to god
nothing wrong with shorts
and a shirt like that for secular
activities right but for sacred
activities you should have a special
garment because you're going to meet the
king of the universe you know that that
is very true and i co-sign what you say
i have seen particularly on television
as of late it seems to be
the way that that worship is going in
some churches to be as
as dressed down as you possibly can be
jeans
jeans with rips in them polo shirts that
kind of thing the i think the the the
the standard we want to set is to give
god your best christ gave his best
heaven gave its best we should in turn
be willing to give our very very best
there was a time when you had just uh
remember when you were younger you had
sabbath clothes you had sabbath suits
you'd get your sabbath clothes out on
friday evening and that was only one on
saturday and for some of us only on
saturday in the morning in the afternoon
you took those off and you put on other
clothes but the idea was to give god the
very best you have my good friend the
late cd brooks used to say
the ethic ought not suffer under the
weight of the ethnic
so uh your your ethic ought to be is
going to be informed by your ethnic but
it should not suffer under the weight of
that
the idea is always to give god your very
best good point
i think we can close this question with
the principles that we find in first
timothy chapter 2 verse 9 and i think
the same principles although they apply
yeah they apply to dress and we can also
apply it to the hat issue it says here
in like manner also that the women adorn
themselves in modest apparel with
propriety and moderation
not with braided hair or gold or perils
or costly clothing you see a costly
clothing but which is proper for women
professing godliness with good works so
the hat should be modest according to
the culture
not uh
something that you are going to have to
pay
a lot of money for a hat
and will attract attention to yourself
so this these principles should be
applied to your culture to your context
and
so that we can also
please god in those contexts and
circumstances now one one final thing
first corinthians 11 also gives the
impression that a woman's long hair
would would be the covering
and that men
should should actually have short hair
as compared to women
and uh and the apostle paul actually
refers to that in the context of
creation
so you know that's something that
perhaps can be pursued
in another place and at another time
yes
okay
we have another question here from hans
dicker
this question
is about
um the salvation of the slaves
it says dear i'd like to know team
i have a question based on the below
quote from ellen g white
and i'd like to ask pastor boy if you
can read that quote it says here i saw
that the slave master
i saw that the slave master will have to
answer for the soul of his slave
whom he has kept in ignorance
and the sins of the slave will be
visited upon the master
god cannot take to heaven the slave who
has been kept in ignorance and
degradation
knowing nothing of god or the bible
fearing nothing but his master's lash
and holding a lower position than the
brutes
but he does the best thing for him that
a compassionate god can do
he permits him to be as if he had not
been
while the master must endure the seven
last plagues and then come up in the
second resurrection
and suffer the second most awful death
then the justice of god
will be satisfied
wow so the question is does this quote
mean that there is a third group of
people which do not resurrect during the
first resurrection neither during the
second one after the millennium these
quotes come from the book early writings
looking forward to your findings thank
you
this is a very sensitive quote
because it talks about the slaves
who
didn't know about god or the bible who
will not be saved but at the same time
won't be punished
so the question is is there a third
group
or
where can we put the slaves who are not
safe in what group well she makes it
very clear that they'll be as if they've
never been
they're not going to resurrect yes in
other words
and there's a phrase that really
makes it clear in my mind
the part where it says
fearing nothing but his must master's
lash
and holding a lower position
than the brutes
by brutes she means the animals the
animals yes now do animals have a
conscience do are animals going to
suffer the second death because is a dog
going to suffer second death because he
bit his master
of course not
they're not that you know they don't
have a sense of right or wrong
what ellen white is saying here is that
the slave had no sense of right or wrong
and therefore
god will not hold the slave accountable
for the sins that he committed sin is he
who knows how to do good yes and doesn't
do it yes
several things are working into this
because it is it is a sensitive issue
we start out with the the
trying to avoid using a 50 cent word
here but
we start out with the the basic
understanding and i'm looking at my time
that
god is love first john for it he said
love us not
love with god no no no not god because
god is love do a thought it's a love
the second thing is god does all things
well i'm trying to conflate my verses
here
so we start out with the understanding
that god is going to do the best he can
for every human being he proved that
when he sent christ to die amen okay so
that's that's prima facie that's on
that's on the ground
so what is the best that god can do for
someone who has no knowledge of jesus
christ i mean i've got you've got acts 4
or 4 16.
john 14 6
no man cometh unto the father there's
one name we're about so you have to have
jesus amen and the knowledge of jesus to
be acceptable for heaven and if you if
you don't have that you are not
acceptable for heaven
um
you can't get there
so you've got the person who is
unacceptable and then you've got the the
other person the master who made him
unacceptable so judgment has to be
rendered on the person who who made him
an acceptance but it would be not right
to take a person who has no knowledge of
christ into heaven uh
because christ is the
the groundswell the basis of our of our
salvation experience so god is doing the
best he can given this situation created
by man by the way yes uh
in holding back uh
for another person i i asked the
question one time in a in a meeting
what's the worst thing one person can do
to another i'm trying to go kind of fast
uh and someone said well kill him i said
no not really the worst thing you can do
is withhold the gospel message from
somebody
uh that's the worst thing it is killing
them and it is killing them in in a way
because
um you you are sensing sentencing them
to the ultimate death yes uh they're not
acceptable for christ and that's what
this this text is trying to show us and
that's what this question is alluding to
and the sad thing is
that many of the slave owners
claimed
to be christian yes
and that was the only image of
christianity
that the fl that the slaves saw
and so you know that would actually lead
the slave to hate they hate god the
christ of the master yeah so they didn't
they didn't have light
so god is not going to hold them god is
not going to hold them accountable and
punish them right
for the light that was withheld both in
word and it is an example yes by the
master well done well said
i think the bible basis for this would
be also
with the text that pastor ca shared
romans 2 verses 11 and 12 it says for
there is no partiality with god
for as many as have sinned without the
law will also perish without the law
and as many as have sinned in the law
will be judged by allah
[Music]
it is it is a difficult question for
some people to grasp
because
some people stumble with this idea of
god
not saving someone because of someone
else
or
or god destroying people or just sending
them to eternal
death
but we have to understand on the basis
of christ the only way of salvation even
if christ wanted to save them
there is only one way and that's christ
and it didn't have the opportunity
because of the slave master
then he will account it on the slave
master but not on the slave
yeah yeah what's that because because
the slave matter man
is guilty
of the slave
not knowing the gospel message
yes and not having the light and not
having a life okay our time is running
out
thank you for sending your questions we
want to also invite you to download our
app if you want to see what questions
have been answered
go to our app some tv that's how you can
find it and there you will see there is
a section for i'd like to know
and if you want to know if your question
has been answered check the app and
there you can do your research thank you
again for joining us and thank you for
sending your questions please keep
sending them if your question hasn't
been answered and we will be pleased
to discuss it here in our program see
you next time god bless you
[Music]
you